aus aktuellem anlass an diesem sonntag
und auch nach neun uhr das zdf
morgenmagazin interessante pläne gestern
abend der israelische präsident bennett
ministerpräsident flog zuerst nach
moskau sprach dort drei stunden mit
präsident putin flog dann direkt nach
berlin das ist sind bilder vom
kanzleramt um am späten abend noch mit
bundeskanzler scholz zu sprechen israel
hat ja gute beziehungen zu beiden
ländern russland und die ukraine 90
minuten soll das gespräch nur gedauert
haben mit bundeskanzler scholz bis in
die nacht hinein was genau da besprochen
wurde das wissen wir nicht man arbeite
wohl aber weiter daran den krieg in der
ukraine zitat so schnell wie irgend
möglich zu beenden hieß es dann danach
wie gesagt viel mehr ist nicht raus doch
wie soll das gelingen den krieg
möglichst schnell zu beenden präsident
putin jedenfalls scheint weiter
entschlossen neue ungewöhnliche bilder
von ihm gestern im russischen
staatsfernsehen putin sitzt mit
flugbegleiterinnen der russischen
fluggesellschaft aeroflot sehr nah
aneinander an einem großen tisch und
trinkt tee ganz ohne abstand und das ist
deshalb auch ungewöhnlich weil die
bilder die wir ja in letzter zeit von
ihnen gesehen haben wenn man welche
gesehen hat dann sitzt er alleine an
diesem großen tisch und selbst seine
engsten militärs sitzen in weiter
entfernung man muss allerdings dazu
sagen es gibt ernstzunehmende hinweise
von westlichen experten dass das treffen
so nicht stattgefunden hat und dass das
video ein fake es oder teilweise dass
irgendwas könnte sein dass irgendwas
nicht stimmt mit dem video letztlich
wissen wir es nicht interessant ist aber
in jedem fall dass das russische
staatsfernsehen diese bilder
veröffentlicht hat und normalität und
nail suggerieren will ja und in der
ukraine selbst da gehen die kämpfe am
elften tag weiter und auch die flucht
von sehr vielen ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer sonja holstein berichtet
die stadt in knapp 30 kilometer
nordwestlich von kiew
sie wollen weg raus aus dem beschuss aus
den trümmern aus den flammen frauen
kinder einige männer mittlerweile
befinden sich nach angaben des
un-flüchtlingshilfswerks fast 15
millionen menschen auf der flucht vor
dem krieg in der ukraine
auch aus mario pohl wollten die
einwohner entkommen auf eine feuerpause
hatten sich die kriegsparteien geeinigt
um mehr als 200.000 menschen sicher aus
der umzingelten hafenstadt und dem
nahegelegenen wollen nova
herauszubringen die feuerpause hielt
nicht gegenseitige schuldzuweisungen
geburtstag wir hören auf social media
dass die behörden von mario pohl sich
weigern den bewohnern die möglichkeit zu
geben über den vom russischen militär
eingerichteten humanitären korridor
auszureisen
was die russische seite sagt stimmt
nicht sie fahren damit fort mario pohl
zu zerstören deswegen haben wir
beschlossen unsere bürger zurück zu
bringen weil es auf den straßen nicht
sicher ist
überprüfen lässt sich weder das eine
noch das andere
die mobilmachung geht währenddessen
weiter junge ukrainer 19 jahre alt
studentin melden sich freiwillig
meine mutter hat gesagt geh nicht
aber er will kämpfen wie die anderen
auch am abend fordert präsident selensky
seine landsleute erneut auf gegen
invasion und besetzung zu kämpfen wo
immer sich die gelegenheit bietet es ist
nötig rauszugehen und dieses böse aus
unseren städten von unserem land zu
vertreiben so dass keine sogenannten
volks republiken entstehen können in
denen ein normales leben einfach nicht
möglich ist sondern es nur sklaverei
gibt auf ihren knien
seit drei tagen ist die südukrainischen
stadt reaktion in russischer hand doch
der zivile widerstand scheint auch dort
ungebrochen gestern gingen hunderte
gegen die besatzer auf die straße
nicht unerwähnt lassen dass auch viele
menschen in russland auf die straße
gehen um gegen diesen krieg zu
demonstrieren und das kann man schon
mutig nennen wenn man sie wie putin
ansonsten gegendemonstranten und
demonstranten vorgegangen ist und vor
allen dingen jetzt zudem auch noch die
presse zensiert umso eindrucksvoller
sind diese bilder über die wir gerade
gesprochen haben von denen wir gar nicht
wissen wie man die einordnung ja das ist
eine große aufgabe für uns die bilder
die uns natürlich auch über die sozialen
netzwerke erreichen einzuordnen und das
zdf hat ja auch genau so wie die ard die
berichterstattung aus moskau ausgesetzt
bis auf weiteres und trotzdem berichten
wir ja weiter mit agenturmaterial aber
es wird nicht einfacher in diesem krieg
und wir berichten natürlich auch live
weiter aus der ukraine dort ist unsere
kollegin katrin eigendorf katrin
eigendorf die für uns und für das zdf
aus der west ukraine
berichtet und auch schon den ganzen
morgen an diesem sonntagmorgen für uns
zur verfügung steht hier sehen wir noch
mal den ort das ist südwestlich von kiew
katrin was kannst du uns an diesem
elften tag des krieges in der ukraine
sagen wie ist das land ich sage mal an
diesem krieg sonntag aufgewacht
ja wir sind ja hier heute morgen bei
einem gottesdienst dabei gewesen und ich
würde die stimmung mal so beschreiben
dass viele viele leute weinen die lage
als ganz ganz katastrophal empfinden und
sehr sehr darauf hoffen dass die
unterstützung der internationalen
gemeinschaft bekommen was ich ganz ganz
erschüttert und traurig fand ist wie
viele familien hier mit ihren kindern
sind und wie die kinder teilweise 8 19
jährige uns ganz klar die lage schildern
die sind im prinzip in den letzten tagen
zu erwachsenen geworden und sagen die
nato muss die ukraine unterstützen es
ist wichtig dass der luftraum hier
geschlossen wird das sagt mir ein
zehnjähriger und alexander ein junge mit
dem ich hier gerade gesprochen habe der
wollte sogar sich hier vor unserer
kamera stellen um dem deutschen publikum
die lage zu schildern
das ist die stimmung hier unter den
menschen und
ich bin selber als reporterin auch immer
wieder erschüttert ja wie ja wie diese
humanitäre katastrophe jeden tag hier
weitergeht und im prinzip die menschen
haben überhaupt gar keine hoffnung dass
russland hier diesen beschuss einstellt
ihre einzige hoffnung also aller
menschen mit denen wir hier reden ist
die internationale unterstützung ihr
glaubt niemand mehr der russischen
regierung niemand hier glaubt mehr daran
dass putin bereit ist humanitäre
korridore einzurichten dass putin bereit
ist hier humanitäre hilfe auch
zuzulassen wir haben gehört dass zum
beispiel sich heute morgen fünf züge
aufs rad schiff ausgemacht haben die
stadt verlassen haben aber die menschen
sind dort einfach eingestiegen in der
hoffnung durchzukommen keiner rechnet
damit dass dieser zug nicht beschlossen
werden könnte katrin lass uns noch einen
moment nach russland schauen du hast ja
auch viele jahre als korrespondentin aus
moskau berichtet es gibt bilder vom
russischen präsidenten putin eigentlich
zum ersten mal seit kriegsbeginn in
denen er mit normalen russinnen und
russen zu sehen ist nicht nur mit seinem
machtapparat wir sehen hier gerade noch
mal die bilder das sind sein treffen mit
flugbegleiterinnen von aeroflot wir
wissen nicht genau ob die bilder
wirklich echt sind oder nicht oder ob
sie teilweise manipuliert wurden was
sind deine einschätzung zur ja zur messe
dieser bilder die das russische
staatsfernsehen gestern gezeigt hat
ja ich glaube dass es keine große rolle
spielt ob es sich hier um eine montage
handelt oder nicht auch die ukrainische
experten gehen davon aus dass es eine
montage ist weil es ja bekannt dass
putin sich nicht einmal mit seinen
engsten mitarbeitern mehr auf körper
abstand zusammensetzt aber die botschaft
ist hier wichtig die ausgestrahlt werden
soll putin sieht sich immer mehr unter
druck in seiner person isoliert vom volk
das ist das image was er hier beseitigen
will er will hier mit im prinzip sagen
das ist meine interpretation
ich bin euer präsident ich bin ganz nah
am volk ich bin im prinzip dazu
legitimiert diesen krieg zu führen das
ist ein krieg des russischen volkes
gegen die ukraine und nicht ein krieg
des präsidenten gegen die ukraine dies
ist natürlich für ihn wichtig um diesen
krieg weiterhin zu legitimieren denn wir
sehen ja wachsenden widerstand auch in
der bevölkerung trotz drakonischer
strafen die drohen gehen menschen auf
die straße die presse wird radikal
zensiert aber es gibt mittlerweile auch
soldatenmütter zum beispiel die sagen
wieso schickt putin unsere söhne in
diesen unsinnigen krieg und der
widerstand in der bevölkerung wächst von
tag zu tag und das ist für putin
natürlich zunehmend ein problem
vielen dank katrin für deine
einschätzung und für seine
berichterstattung aus der west ukraine
live war dass katrin eigendorf danke
und von der ukraine gehen wir gleich
weiter und zwar zu unserer kollegin
patricia schäfer die steht für uns an
der ungarisch ukrainischen grenze erst
mal einen schönen guten morgen patricia
1,5 millionen menschen sollen laut
nhc er auf der flucht seien die meisten
innerhalb der ukraine aber viele wollen
natürlich auch aus wollen richtung
westen wie ist denn die situation dort
vor ort was erzählen wir die menschen
tatsächlich hat die ukrainische
regierung gesagt geht ruhig über ungarn
da gibt es geringere wartezeiten und
tatsächlich ist hier in sachen ii wo wir
stehen am bahnhof kommt ein zug aus der
grenzstadt auf der anderen seite aus job
und der kommt mehrfach am tag hier an
und die leute werden dann weiter
transportiert sie können weiterfahren
wenn sie wollen nach budapest von dort
aus weiter das geht alles hier
reibungslos mit relativ geringen
wartezeiten
wir dürfen allerdings sieht nicht sehr
nach bahnhof aus hier hinter mir wie ich
wieder am bahnhof drehen das war bis
gestern noch ungehindert möglich aber
jetzt hat sich das gesetz geändert das
stellen wir hier fest in ungarn regeln
ändern sich sehr schnell und auch in
bezug auf die flüchtlinge kommen später
noch darauf zurück was sie hier sehen
sind trucks aus rodgau einen
speditionsunternehmer dort hatte die
idee hierüber zu fahren die hilfsgüter
tatsächlich selber hier anzuliefern lkw
fahrer können was was in dieser krise
tatsächlich gebraucht wird das machen
sie nun haben 120 tonnen hilfsgüter von
privatleuten von firmen die dort
gespendet wurden 80 prozent lebensmittel
dabei und fahren jetzt zwei davon fahren
noch weiter nach
auf die nachwuchs corot auf die
ukrainische seite das wird weiter
transportiert bis nach kiew und fressen
also wirklich ins kriegsgebiet dann von
ukrainischen spediteuren die das
übernehmen also wirklich hier große
hilfe die ankommt in sachen die an der
ukrainischen grenze wir sind nur zwei
kilometer von der grenze entfernt das
muss man ja insgesamt sagen also die
hilfsbereitschaft bis hierher ist
riesengroß also so wie du es gerade
geschildert hat wir erleben in polen die
riesengroße hilfsbereitschaft sowohl von
seiten der politik als auch von seiten
der bevölkerung wie ist das in umgang
also erst mal sieht das sehr sehr
freundlich aus die flüchtenden werden
wirklich mit offenen armen empfangen von
hunderten von freiwilligen es gibt
teilweise fast mehr freiwillige als
flüchtlinge hat man den eindruck es gibt
essen getränke decken toiletten es wird
wenn gespräch angeboten schlafplätze das
funktioniert hervorragend und die
politiker lassen sich auch sehr gerne
sehen in diesen zentren wo die menschen
erstmal erstversorgt werden und
aufgenommen werden die kehrseite der
medaille ist und das wird in den
ungarischen medien überhaupt nicht
berichtet wir haben gestern gedreht in
einem register aktionszentrum 85
kilometer von der grenze entfernt wo
ukrainische flüchtlinge hingebracht
werden die keine nicht vollständig
gültige papiere haben das heißt die
keine biometrischen pässe haben und auch
wenn eine familie zum beispiel nur die
oma ohne biometrischen pass dabei hat
oder der vater kein hat die anderen aber
schon werden allen die pässe abgenommen
so erzählen die uns das und es wird auch
gar nicht gesagt wann sie wieder
bekommen die sitzen dann also ohne auto
ohne transportmöglichkeit in diesem
zentrum fest für tage teilweise und
kommen einfach nicht weiter was die
offizielle begründung ist es wurde uns
noch keine genannt und wie gesagt die
emotion medienberichten nicht darüber
dann bisher erst mal danke patricia
schäfer für uns an der ungarisch
ukrainischen grenze danke dir
ich glaube da brauchst auch noch ein
bisschen koordinierungsbedarf auf eben
auch was die flüchtlingssituation angeht
vor einer stunde zwei stunden inzwischen
schon glaube ich haben wir mit unserem
usa korrespondenten matti wissen
gesprochen denn auch dort gibt es einige
neue entwicklungen am abend hinsichtlich
des krieges in der ukraine näher so gab
es ein weiteres telefonat zwischen dem
us-präsidenten und dem ukrainischen
präsidenten und hier die einordnung
unseres korrespondenten
[Musik]
in diesem gespräch hat joe biden dem
ukrainischen amtskollegen von ihm
versprochen dass er druck machen wird
auf den amerikanischen kongress da geht
es um zehn milliarden dollar die amerika
braucht um dann die hilfslieferungen an
die ukraine noch einmal massiv
aufzustocken aber auch die lieferungen
von waffen darunter auch boden
luftraketen die natürlich sehr hilfreich
sein könnten um die russische lufthoheit
zu brechen ob das klappt will den
nächsten tagen sehen beide haben begrüßt
dass die großen kreditkartenunternehmen
mastercard und visa ihren
zahlungsverkehr komplett in russland
eingestellt haben und im weißen haus
wird zurzeit erwogen inwieweit amerika
vielleicht auch seine ölimporte aus
russland einstellen könnte das sind rund
200.000 barrel pro tag die amerika
bekommt das sind aber nur drei prozent
des gesamtbedarfs der usa das problem
ist dadurch würden die benzinpreise
natürlich hier weiter klettern und vor
allen dingen würde druck entstehen auf
die europäischen verbündeten ähnliches
zu tun und das weiße haus will auf
keinen fall durch einen alleingang die
geschlossenheit der verbündeten in
irgendeiner form gefährden deswegen kann
das nur eine maßnahme sein die man
gemeinsam beschließt
aktuelle informationen waren das von
unserem korrespondenten aus washington
und jetzt wollen wir auf die situation
der flüchtenden aus der ukraine schauen
1,5 millionen menschen sollen auf der
flucht seien die meisten von ihnen haben
innerhalb der ukraine vielleicht
unterschlupf gefunden manche sind aber
bereits auch hier bei uns in deutschland
angekommen insgesamt bisher fast
30.000 nach angaben der bundespolizei
wir sprechen gleich mit berlins
regierende bürgermeisterin frau es gibt
über das thema davor der bericht von
dagmar henning
wieder ein zug aus dem osten wieder hat
er hunderte geflüchtete an bord ankunft
am berliner hauptbahnhof bedeutet für
sie in sicherheit seien auf der unteren
ebene ein großes improvisiertes
willkommens zentrum hunderte freiwillige
arbeiten hier um die geflüchteten mit
essen zu versorgen und unterkünfte zu
vermitteln
marina und ihre töchter sind seit
einigen tagen in berlin wurden in einem
apartment hotel in kreuzberg
einquartiert nach tagelangen angriffen
auf ihre stadt hatte sich marina
entschlossen aus rocky iv zu fliehen
am 28 februar nahm ich meine beiden
kinder an die hand so wie sie angezogen
waren und dann gingen wir zu fuß zum
bahnhof so etwa sechs bis sieben
kilometer
marina und die kinder finden platz im
zug zwei tage voller angst dauert die
reise nach belieben
uns wurde gesagt schließt alle fenster
licht aus handy aus damit wir nicht
geortet werden es war sehr still der zug
fuhr langsam und hielt durfte
florian wichelmann ist der hotelchef und
leitet die initiative robert kainz in
der 40 hotels ihre zimmer kostenlos zur
verfügung stellen 460 geflüchtete werden
so versorgt da kam viele sachspenden von
freunden da kam eine große
supermarktkette auf uns zu und hat uns
angerufen und gesagt wenn unsere allianz
unsere hotels was brauchen können die
auch liefern marina die 14 jährige
margarita und die zwölfjährige xenia
sind in sicherheit doch die sorge um die
verwandten in der heimat bleibt
speziellen papa oma und opa papa wird
durchhalten aber
stark
marina versucht ihre mittlere schwester
in der ukraine zu erreichen
diese will mit mann und kind fliehen
keine antwort
eine andere verwandte ist erreichbar hat
schlechte nachrichten
die schwester ist auf der flucht mit dem
auto mit mann und kind auf eine mine
gefahren
alle sind tot
wir brechen das interview ab der krieg
in der ukraine hat marina auch hier in
berlin erreicht
ganz schlimme schicksale auch hier in
berlin und ich begrüße berlins
regierende bürgermeisterin franziska
gefahr guten morgen frau
gefahr in berlin und brandenburg kommt
derzeit die meisten geflüchteten
innerhalb deutschlands an wie ist die
stadt berlin darauf vorbereitet ja wir
haben binnen einer woche ein extrem
dynamisches geschehen am anfang waren es
45 menschen die wir untergebracht
mittlerweile kommen über 10.000 am tag
und das ist eine riesen herausforderung
die wir versuchen mit verschiedenen
mitteln zu bewältigen einerseits
natürlich über unsere ankunft zentren
notunterkünfte geflüchteten unterkünfte
hostels jugendherbergen aber natürlich
auch mit dem großen privaten engagement
viele helferinnen und helfer und es geht
nur gemeinsam im moment wir kommen
zunehmend an unsere grenzen und die
meisten kommen tatsächlich in berlin an
und deshalb ist es jetzt so wichtig dass
es endlich eine bundesweite organisation
und -verteilung auch gibt weil wir
einfach in diesen grössenordnungen dass
mit den vorhandenen strukturen hier in
berlin nicht alleine schaffen wir haben
tausende menschen untergebracht in den
letzten tagen viele sind auch bei
verwandten und freunden untergekommen
aber es ist eine riesige herausforderung
kritiker sorgen berlin überlässt viele
aufgaben den ehrenamtlichen dabei
bräuchte es eine struktur und jemand der
den überblick behält wie versuchen sie
das zu schaffen wir haben schon im
letzten wochenende sofort ein
krisenmanagement ukraine hier
eingerichtet im land berlin es wird
koordiniert durch die senatskanzlei in
enger zusammenarbeit mit der
integrations verwaltung aber auch mit
der innenverwaltung und finanzverwaltung
wir haben drei große arbeitsbereiche das
thema ankunft strukturen das thema
unterbringung und dass die man auch
sicherheit es ist so dass wir rund um
die uhr
schon unterbringen hier tausende auch in
landes unterkünften wir finanzieren auch
ein eben die hilfsorganisationen
teilweise wir haben jetzt verhandlungen
für ein größeres ankunft zentrum was in
der nächsten woche ans netz gehen soll
wir haben unterbringungs kapazitäten in
größenordnung geschaffen und es ist
natürlich sehr wichtig dass wir auch mit
den anderen bundesländern zusammen
arbeiten brandenburg hat uns sehr
unterstützt
aber ich sage es nochmal es braucht
jetzt endlich und wir hören dass der
bund das jetzt tun will auch die gesamt
verteilung im bundesgebiet auch durch
das dampf durch das bundesamt für
migration und flüchtlinge ohne das wird
es nicht gehen ich kann ihnen sagen wir
laden hier nicht die arbeit auf den
ehrenamtlichen ab sondern es ist eine
gemeinsame anstrengung wir sind dankbar
für das ehrenamtliche engagement
aber wir sind auch genauso dankbar für
all diejenigen die in der
landesregierung gerade im moment in
unserem verwaltungen landesamt für
flüchtlinge dafür arbeiten dass es auch
gelingt und dass wir diese große zahl
bewältigen sie fordern vor gefahr
unterstützung vom bund geht es doch nur
um die verteilung oder was kann der bund
noch für das bundesland berlin jetzt tun
was brauchen sie es geht zum beispiel
darum dass man auch die entscheidung
eben trifft nicht alle sonderzüge und
busse in berlin an lernen zu lassen
sondern zu sagen wir gehen gleich von
vornherein so daran dass das eben wenn
züge und busse von polen kommen dass sie
eben in unterschiedliche deutsche städte
gehen dass verteilungs thema ist eines
das registrierungs thema ist ein zweites
wichtiges thema im moment wissen wir
nicht wie viele menschen sind auch bei
privat untergekommen ist es sehr wichtig
dass sie registriert werden damit eben
auch hilfeleistungen dann erfolgen kann
und dann kommt natürlich das thema wie
können diese menschen einen
aufenthaltsstatus und ein arbeitsrecht
bekommen die eu hatte am donnerstag
entschieden über den aufenthaltsstatus
als kriegs geflüchtete damit verbunden
ist das arbeitsrecht das ist enorm
wichtig das muss jetzt im bundesrecht in
dieser woche dringend umgesetzt werden
damit die menschen die hierher kommen
eben nicht nur verteilt werden
untergebracht werden erstversorgt werden
sondern damit auch klar ist sie haben
eine geschützte bleibeperspektive für
einen bestimmten zeitraum und sie haben
das recht zu arbeiten denn sehr viele
sind gut qualifiziert und sie brauchen
auch sowohl für die kinder in der
betreuung des reiten wir jetzt ja auch
vor in unseren schulen aber eben auch
die eltern eine möglichkeit zu arbeiten
selbst irgendwie anzukommen um die zeit
auch vernünftig zu verbringen denn das
schlimmste ist in einer unterkunft zu
sitzen und zu warten und nicht zu wissen
was passiert insofern ganz klar arbeits
perspektive sozial versorgungs
perspektive und für die kinder eine
entsprechende beschulung und eine
registrierung damit wir wissen wie viel
im land sind denn klar ist auch
diejenigen die jetzt privat menschen
aufnehmen dass es großartig dass so
viele menschen das tun aber das ist ja
keine dauerlösung jeder der zu hause in
der wohnung menschen hat wird auch nach
einer gewissen zeit sagen jetzt muss
landes unterbringung greifen und das
heißt diese menschen sind nicht weg
sondern sie werden auch zusätzlich dazu
kommen und das muss getragen sein als
nationale aufgabe in der
gesamtverantwortung auch aller
bundesländer und der bundesregierung
berlin schafft es nicht allein klare
forderungen an den bund von berlins
regierende bürgermeisterin franziska
giffey vielen dank das hörte man darf
ja und vielleicht geht es ihm ja auch so
dass sie morgens wach werden und das
erste was sie dann tun es erstmal aufs
handy gucken was es eigentlich so neues
aus der ukraine gibt was es für
neuigkeiten und informationen zum krieg
gibt auf der zdf heute app gibt es immer
einen sehr guten überblick das
wichtigste finden sie dort in kürze so
heißt die
rubrik und da sehen sie zum beispiel
heute was bisher passiert ist die lage
in mario pohl wird immer schwieriger und
da gibt es jetzt die erste agentur eine
neue information dass man ab 11 uhr
versucht den flucht korridor wieder zu
öffnen so dass die zivilisten die stadt
verlassen können das hat ja bisher nicht
wirklich funktioniert außerdem heftige
angriffe auf ukrainische großstädte wie
kiew und kharkiv außerdem mastercard und
visa setzen ihre geschäfte in russland
aus israels ministerpräsident darüber
haben wir in der sendung bereits
berichtet war zu besuch bei putin und
dann anschließend auch bei urlaubs hier
in deutschland und morgen ist eine
dritte gesprächsrunde geplant zwischen
russland und der ukraine und wir nehmen
sie mit noch in weitere 20 minuten zdf
morgenmagazin
und jetzt live aus berlin das zdf
[Musik]
im studio dunja hayali und andreas wunn
einen schönen guten morgen um 9 uhr 29
wir senden am sonntag und länger als
sonst und in diesen zeiten ist es immer
gut und wichtig vor allen dingen auch
gespräche zur aktuellen lage zu führen
wir haben im laufe der sendung und
werden es noch mit unseren
korrespondenten und korrespondenten
gesprochen unter anderem
mit
wir sind an die grenze gegangen zwischen
ihnen wir haben nach kokain in die best
marine geschaltet und wollen ihn bilder
aus der nacht zeigen aus der nähe von
kiew
dort wurde eine brücke gesprengt rang
von ukrainischen streitkräften man
könnte vermuten dass diese brücke
gesprengt wurde damit man den russischen
militärs den weg in die hauptstadt
natürlich unmöglich machen kann
jedenfalls über diesen weg und die
letzten bilder die sie gerade gesehen
haben waren flüchtende menschen die eben
aus dem großraum kiew richtung westen
drängt gleich die nachrichten dafür aber
kurz noch mit wem wir gesprochen haben
in dieser sendung alle gespräche das
wissen sie immer auch zum nachschauen
auf der zdf heute ganz kurz und kompakt
um kurz nach sieben haben wir mit erik
marquardt gesprochen von bündnis 90/die
grünen er ist eu-abgeordneter er war in
der ukraine ist jetzt auf dem rückweg er
hat uns geschildert was er dort an der
grenze gesehen hat und auch über die
verteilung der geflüchteten in der eu um
kurz nach acht habe ich gesprochen mit
carsten linnemann stellvertretender
cdu-vorsitzender in dem gespräch ging es
vor allen dingen auch um das was auf uns
hier in deutschland zukommt in sachen
preise öl und gas und aber auch über
eine mögliche wehrpflicht und gerade
eben hat andreas gesprochen mit
franziska giffey sie ist die regierende
bürgermeisterin von berlin und da ging
es um die in teilen jedenfalls
schleppende hilfe nicht von seiten der
ehrenamtlichen sondern eher von seiten
des senats hat aber gesagt da ist jetzt
alles
organisiert sie hat vor allem gesagt sie
braucht hilfe vom bund keine stadt auch
berlin ich schaffe das wahrscheinlich
alleine also klar der appell der
regierende bürgermeisterin dass der bund
mehr koordinieren und mehr verteilen
soll so und jetzt ganz klar das ist
nämlich einfach wir geben weiter zu den
nachrichten und die sind in mainz guten
morgen & morgen
guten morgen dankeschön nach berlin
guten morgen liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer willkommen zu heute express in
der ukraine gehen die russischen
angriffe auf großstädte wie mario pohl
weiter nach der gescheiterten feuerpause
gestern soll es heute ab 11 uhr einen
neuen evakuierungs versuch von
zivilistinnen geben die strategisch
wichtige hafenstadt im süden meldet
dramatische zustände es gibt offenbar
viele tote und verletzte keinen strom
keine heizung heftige angriffe gab es
zuletzt auch in der region rund um kiew
nach angaben des ukrainischen
verteidigungsministers sind bislang mehr
als 60.000 ukraine aus dem ausland
zurückgekehrt um ihr land zu verteidigen
internationale vermittlungsversuche sind
bisher gescheitert einen neuen anlauf
machte gestern israels ministerpräsident
benjamin
raich und besuch bei russlands präsident
putin traf bennett bundeskanzler scholz
in berlin ihr gemeinsames ziel den krieg
in der ukraine so schnell wie möglich zu
beenden
als reaktion auf den einmarsch in die
ukraine setzen die beiden weltgrößten
kreditkartenanbieter visa und mastercard
ihre geschäfte mit russland aus die
russische zentralbank teilte mit
kundinnen und kunden könnten im land
noch geld abheben einkäufe bei
ausländischen online anbietern sollen
nicht mehr möglich sein in vielen
ländern der welt gingen zehntausende
menschen gegen den russischen angriff
auf die straße wie hier in paris zogen
tausende mit ukrainischen flaggen und
transparenten durch die stadt in london
forderten sie am trafalgar square stoppt
putins krieg und 2000 demonstrierende in
münchen bildeten eine menschenkette
zu aktuellen corona lage in deutschland
die zahlen steigen das robert koch
institut meldet 116
1809 und 80 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden das sind 8
1976 mehr als vor einer woche die sieben
tage incidents liegt jetzt bei 1.200
31,1
zweiter wettkampftag bei den paralympics
in peking zweite silbermedaille für
anna-lena forster die mono ski
fahrerinnen verpasste im super g nur um
elf hundertstel den ersten platz gold
ging wie schon in der abfahrt an die
japanerin naoko foster kann auf weitere
medaillen in ihren paradedisziplinen
slalom und super kombi hoffen
so weit heute express weiter geht es im
morgenmagazin mit dem wetter und das hat
benjamin stufe für uns einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]
vielen dank maria und guten morgen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer herzlich
willkommen zum moma wetter am sonntag
und wenn wir auf die iso barren karte
blicken dann sehen wir ein mächtiges
hochdruckgebiet bei den britischen
inseln hochdruckgebiet martin das wird
sich in den nächsten tagen noch weiter
ausdehnen und das beschert und so ruhige
und sehr sonnige tage allerdings bringt
es uns auch sehr viel kühle luft über
die ostsee da nimmt die feuchtigkeit auf
und das ergebnis sehen wir heute morgen
in der nordost region unseres landes
hochnebel und dichte wolken das wird
über ein tag so ein bisschen löchriger
werden aber im moment ist es doch sehr
dicht ganz anders sieht es im westen und
im süden aus klare verhältnisse dort und
entsprechend kalt ist es heute morgen
wenn wir auf die temperaturen blicken am
alpenrand minus sechs grad minus sechs
grad aber auch in zinnwald georgenfeld
im landkreis sächsische schweiz
osterzgebirge also sehr frostig das
gegenteil mit der sonne heute morgen
schon fünf grad plus gibt es in speyer
und damit sind wir beim wettergeschehen
für diesen sonntag vormittag der sehen
wir noch dieses wolken paket über der
nordost region mit allem was da von der
ostsee an feuchtigkeit mit konnte auch
mal ein kleiner schauer mit dem spiel
sein im westen und vor allem im
südwesten aber schon intensiver
sonnenschein dort auch am
konsequentesten am oberrhein wirklich
den ganzen tag über blauer himmel und
sonne ansonsten muss man eben nordosten
so ein bisschen darauf hoffen dass sich
die wolken lösen im stau der nördlichen
mittelgebirge ist vielleicht im
tagesverlauf auch mal eine schneeflocke
dabei alles in allem ein sonne wolken
mix und insgesamt ein doch sehr
freundlicher sonntag bei
tageshöchsttemperaturen heute zwischen
nicht mehr als ein grad richtung osten
bis neun grad gibt es am oberrhein und
damit sind wir bei den aussichten für
die kommenden drei tage vom tag zu tagen
wird es jetzt sonniger und auch milder
zwei bis neun grad die
tageshöchsttemperaturen am montag am
mittwoch dann schon sechs bis 14 grad
wenn die strömung von nordost auf
südwest dreht dann steht uns eine sehr
freundliche woche bevor soweit zu den
aussichten für den moment kommen sie
damit jetzt gut und steuerfrei in diesem
sonntag
[Musik]
und noch mal herzlich willkommen zu
diesem sonntag morgenmagazin bis 59
senden wir noch hier auf der ard es ist
der elfte tag des krieges ein krieg der
nicht nur analog sondern ja auch digital
geführt wird insbesondere in den
sozialen medien eine fülle von felix
aber natürlich auch von fakten und für
putin ist das so eine art ja eine form
der freien unabhängigen und fakten
basierten presse das nennt er ein
angriff im grunde er sagt schon
informationskrieg also man darf auf gar
keinen fall auch mehr von krieg oder
invasion in russland sprechen genau
deshalb hat er ein gesetz ein gesetz am
freitag unterzeichnet das drakonische
haftstrafen gegen kritische
berichterstattung über die russische
armee vorsieht bis zu 15 jahre haft
drohen demnach für die verbreitung von
sogenannten falsch nachrichten über die
armee tja wenn man einen krieg nicht
mehr krieg nennen darf dann erschwert
dass natürlich auch die arbeit unserer
korrespondenten ard und zdf prüfen
deshalb gerade die folgendes von andreas
gerade angesprochenen gesetzes und
setzten die berichterstattung aus moskau
erst einmal aus von vor ort aus
natürlich berichten wir weiter von den
anderen standorten weiter umfassend über
das geschehen nicht nur in der ukraine
sondern auch in moskau mit agentur
material zum beispiel zum beispiel auch
über ein treffen das angeblich gestern
stattgefunden hat zwischen russlands
präsident putin und normalen bürgerinnen
und bürgern veröffentlicht vom
russischen staatsfernsehen angeblich das
muss man wirklich sehr dick sagen und
schreiben angeblich deshalb weil es eben
ernstzunehmende hinweise auch von
westlichen experten gibt dass dieses
video einfach ein fake ist kann oder
rechts sondern vielleicht auch nicht
vielleicht auch nicht man fragt sich was
das ganze soll annette streicher
das staatliche fernsehen zeigt putin wie
er mit flugbegleiterinnen tee trinkt
dabei wird ab dienstag keine aeroflot
flugzeug mehr ins ausland abheben einzig
nach belarus laut nachrichtenagentur
tass der kreml chef nutzte die kulisse
gestern für ungemütliche botschaften gen
westen die einrichtung einer
flugverbotszone über der ukraine durch
dritte werde man als beteiligung am
bewaffneten konflikt juli wird jeder
schritt in eine solche richtung wird als
intervention angesehen der eine
bedrohung für die russischen truppen
darstellt warnt er die
wirtschaftssanktionen verglich putin mit
einer kriegserklärung
weitere firmen haben gerade den export
nach russland aufgekündigt so die
japanischen hersteller panasonic und
yamaha motor italien hat besitztümer
russischer oligarchen im wert von 140
millionen euro beschlagnahmt eine
härtere gangart schlägt der kreml seit
gestern gegenüber unliebsamer presse ein
so hat putin am freitag ein gesetz
unterzeichnet das drakonische
haftstrafen gegen kritische
berichterstattung über die russische
armee vorsieht bis zu 15 jahre haft
drohen für die verbreitung angeblicher
falsch nachrichten in diesem krieg der
ja auch ein informationskrieg ist in
russland auch nach innen für bedeute
diese gesetzesänderung nicht einfach die
wendung sondern wirklich eine eskalation
denn es ist ja so was heißt
falschinformation eine falschinformation
ist nach diesem verständnis schon wenn
man den krieg als krieg benennt und
man muss sich auch darüber klar sein es
gibt keine rechtssicherheit in russland
und russland schränkt die
informationsmöglichkeiten weiter
drastisch ein das soziale netzwerk
facebook gesperrt der zugang zu twitter
beschränkt da soll ein absoluter
isolations raum geschaffen werden so
kann der russische präsident vor seinen
landsleuten unwidersprochen behaupten
dass gestern wegen mangelnder
bereitschaft der ukrainischen seite
keine zivilisten die ukrainische
großstadt mario pohl über einen
humanitären korridor verlassen konnten
ukrainischen behörden zufolge verletzten
hingegen die russischen truppen die
feuerpause
gestern abend wurde noch bekannt dass
der israelische premier bennett als
vermittler nach russland gereist ist
später weiter zu kanzler scholz nach
berlin
aus dem abgeschirmten kreml gab es zu
dem dreistündigen gespräch keine
nachricht
wie hältst du es mit putin nicht wenige
russen und russinnen werden aufgefordert
stellung zu beziehen ist das richtig ist
das fair diese diskussion wird geführt
spätestens seit der trennung der
münchner philharmoniker von ihrem chef
dirigent die kulturszene also im
gerangel wenn man so will zwischen
freund und feind dazu jetzt ein gespräch
mit jörg [ __ ] ist der direktor des
deutsch russischen museums in berlin
karlshorst guten morgen
guten morgen frau hayali wie weit
sollten oder müssen sich künstler
künstlerinnen zu solchen konflikten
äußern
sie müssen sich überhaupt nicht zu
solchen konflikten äußern sie sind
künstler und ich finde das vollkommen
übertrieben hier frei schwebend
irgendwelche bekenntnisse abzupressen
möchte ich mal fast schon sagen sie sind
natürlich weil sie personen des
öffentlichen lebens sind mehr oder
weniger gehalten sich dazu zu
positionieren aber das jetzt so unter
druck zu tun halte ich für verkehrt muss
man nicht vor allen dingen auch bedenken
dass russen und russinnen die hier leben
vielleicht ja noch familie in russland
haben und sich auch deshalb nicht äußern
aus angst um diese familie
erfolg kommen richtig das ist eine total
verwobene gemeinschaft zwischen hier und
dort zwischen berlin und russland
ukraine ukraine russland das ist im
einzelnen wirklich ganz schwer zu
überblicken und das betrifft natürlich
auch die kulturschaffenden die in diesem
zusammenhang leben und noch mal wir
haben ja nun 20 30 jahre lang diese
europäische liberalität diesen austausch
das des kulturellen gelebt und gepflegt
wir wollen das bis vor bis vor zehn
tagen und wir können das jetzt nicht
einfach chirurgisch mit dem skalpell
durchtrennen sie haben den austausch
schon angesprochen verschiedene deutsche
städte haben ihre partnerschaften jetzt
mit russischen städten gekündigt haben
sie eine idee was das bringen könnte
nein habe ich nicht ich habe natürlich
auch selber für mein haus noch nicht
wirklich den plan wie kann das
weitergehen und es ist auch vollkommen
klar dass wir uns neu sortieren müssen
aber wir sind doch jetzt im augenblick
nicht unter diesem enormen druck sofort
erstmal etwas zu kappen denn wenn es
kaputt ist dann ist es unglaublich viel
schwieriger ist wieder ganz zu bekommen
alle sagen ja permanent es ist putins
krieg damit will man verdeutlichen dass
es eben nicht der krieg der russen
russinnen ist natürlich gibt es in dem
land einige die in den rücken stärken
anderen nicht das sehen wir auch anhand
der demonstration warum haben sie denn
an ihrem museum wenn ich richtig
informiert bin die russische flagge
abgehängt
ich würde es ein bisschen anders
erklären wir haben vor unserem haus 4
nationalflaggen deutschland russland
ukraine belarus weil diese
nationalitäten an der museumsarbeit
aktiv beteiligt sind und an dem
donnerstag letzte woche als der krieg
ausbrach haben wir eine
solidaritätsaktion ein zeichen der
solidarität setzen wollen und haben
beschlossen heute ziehen wir nur die
ukrainische fahne auf und das haben wir
jetzt die letzten tage auch so gelassen
solange eben der krieg läuft wie
unterstützen sie aktuell künstler
künstlerin in beiden ländern gibt es
einen weg
also wir stehen im regen austausch vor
allen dingen auch mit unseren museums
kollegen und vor allen dingen muss ich
sagen mein team ist da auch
multinational also das geht wirklich in
die die verwandtschaftlichen
freundschaftlichen beziehungen hinein da
passiert gerade ganz ganz viel über
diverse medien
tatkräftige hilfe na ja man wird es
sehen ich meine wir sind wir sind bereit
wir haben wie gesagt noch nichts
geklappt das haben wir auch nicht vor
auf absehbare zeit und geben sie uns die
paar tage oder vielleicht auch wochen
dass wir uns dann neu aufstellen dann
bin ich ziemlich sicher dass wir da in
karlshorst eine lösung finden wie wir
auch wirklich helfen können
vielen herzlichen dank für das gespräch
heute bei uns und ihnen auch alles gute
danke und zum ende unserer sendung
sprechen wir noch mal mit unserem
experten walter feichtinger
sicherheits experte und ehemalige
brigadegeneral der österreichischen
armee danke dass sie ab 7 uhr schon bei
uns dabei sind nochmal guten morgen
es gab heute die meldung dass in mario
pohl in der hafenstadt der in der
ukraine ein neuer evakuierungs versuch
gestartet werden soll es gab ja die idee
der humanitären korridore die gestern
nicht funktioniert hat wie schätzen sie
dass wir heute ein ob es eine chance
gibt für die zivilisten oder nicht
die chance auch heute wieder sehr gering
einen fall nach deswegen weil hier sehr
so so so viele zivilisten die hier aus
der stadt zu bringen sind und dass
allein aus kapazitätsgründen schon ein
problem sein kann man muss aber genau
hinschauen weil für mich könnte mario
pohl auch ein muster sein wie man ist
mitmachen möchte weil hier auch in
einkreisung vorbereitet wird er
vielleicht länger wir hören in diesen
tagen viel über logistikprobleme der
russen offenbar ist russland auch
überrascht über die kampfbereitschaft
der ukraine und man hört über die
fehlende moral oder frustration in der
russischen armee ist das ukrainische
propaganda oder haben sie dazu auch
erkenntnisse
das wissen wir leider alle nicht es ist
vollkommen klar dass beide versuchen
beide seiten versuchen mit dem krieg aus
ihrer perspektive darzustellen und die
andere seite zu demoralisieren
aber man kann sich das schon vorstellen
weil hier soldaten aus ganz russland
herbeigeschafft wurden die jetzt
plötzlich in der ukraine in einem kampf
gegen ein bruder volk befinden und da
könnte es für viele ein sehr böses
erwachen geben noch eine kurze letzte
frage herr feichtinger falls booten es
wirklich schafft die ukraine zu erobern
was kommt dann eine marionettenregierung
wird der kiew und das ganze land
anhalten kann
sollte es tatsächlich gelingen hier die
ukraine militärische mal unter kontrolle
zu bringen dann kommt die ganz große
herausforderung nämlich die verwaltung
des landes und alle sicherzustellen wir
wissen eine absolut antirussische
einstellung mittlerweile in der
bevölkerung um selbst wenn es gelingt
hier eine marionettenregierung zu
installieren gehe ich nicht davon aus
dass die eine tatsächliche
amtsgewalt über das ganze land hat sagt
der sicherheitsexperte walter
feichtinger vielen dank nach wien für
heute morgen
ist ja gerne und werden im laufe der
sendung ja auch über die enorme
hilfsbereitschaft berichtet und
gesprochen wenn sie den menschen in der
ukraine helfen wollen dann können sie
das natürlich gerne tun zum beispiel
beim aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
und hier sehen sie es auch geschrieben
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine iban de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden punkt zdf.de oder im
zdf text auf seite 8 190
heute also eine ausgabe des magazins am
sonntag in anbetracht des kriegs
zwischen russland und der ukraine der
invasion also von wladimir putin morgen
startet dann das morgenmagazin wie
gewohnt ab 5 uhr 30 und an diesem
sonntag natürlich alle informationen
auch online und im fernsehen das war es
von uns für heute morgen machen sie es
gut haben sie einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]